[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal
guten abend am ende eines weiteren
kriegs tages vor einer weiteren bangen
nacht für die menschen in der ukraine
bei den verhandlungen zwischen
ukrainischen und russischen
unterhändlern gab es lediglich eine
einigung darauf dass schutz korridore
eingerichtet werden sollen um zivilisten
die flucht zu ermöglichen
außerdem gab es heute ein
telefongespräch zwischen emanuel makro
und wladimir putin das soll geradezu
verheerend verlaufen sein putin trat er
wohl nicht anders auf als in seiner
öffentlichen fernsehansprache heute
abend mit altbekannten tiraden gegen das
angebliche neonazi team der ukrainischen
regierung derweil fallen weiter raketen
und sterben menschen benjamin schikowski
mit eindrücken dieses tages
der schrecken des krieges ist einfach
immer wieder unfassbar plötzlich so nah
in cernys im norden wird am morgen ein
wohnhaus von einer rakete getroffen
alleine hier sterben mindestens 22
menschen
in borodjanka bei kiew tobten die kämpfe
in der nacht als es hell wird sieht man
das ganze ausmaß des wahnsinns
diese fahrzeuge wahrscheinlich russische
auch hier saßen menschen drin
die zerstörung massiv fast überall im
land es gibt heute tausende solcher
bilder der ukrainische präsident bleibt
kämpferisch
wir werden jedes haus jede straße jede
stadt wieder aufbauen und wir sagen den
russen lernt schon mal das wort
wiedergutmachung denn ihr werdet den
vollen preis bezahlen für alles was ihr
uns ukrainern angetan habt
dazu sagt putin nicht der held am abend
eine fernsehansprache mit
heldengeschichten für das eigene volk
google liefere russischen streitkräfte
und die kämpfer aus dem don budge
kämpfen die echte helden die sind
standhaft bleiben sogar nach einer
verletzung in der truppe sie opfern sich
selbst und ihr leben um kameraden zu
retten
überraschend offen spricht putin von
vielen russischen opfern und lässt seine
marine vor der millionenstadt odessa
auffahren
das benachbarte person scheinen die
russischen truppen und ihre panzer jetzt
zu kontrollieren
und ganz im osten wenn dann jetzt da
wurde er krieg schon so lange tobt hier
sind sie einfach nur noch verzweifelt
gehen dürfte es war eine bombe sie
schießen überall die ganze zeit wohin
schießen sie wen wird es treffen ich bin
verloren
in der hauptstadt kiew bauen sie derweil
weiter barrikaden bereiten sich vor auf
den kampf
geht nach hause rufen sie den russischen
soldaten zu ganz im süden des landes und
singen dann ihre hymne der text dazu die
ukraine ist noch nicht tot
[Applaus]
unter schweren beschuss ist seit
kriegsbeginn auch die stadt oaxaca im
nordosten der ukraine
sie liegt nah an der grenze zu russland
und rund 90 kilometer entfernt von
praktiker ist eine stadt mit rund 50.000
einwohnern an einem großen fluss gelegen
sie ihren sehenswürdigkeiten gehört
unter anderem eine barocke kathedrale
diese bilder wiederum entstanden vor
drei tagen nach schwerem artillerie oder
raketenbeschuss bei dem es viele tote
gehabt
von dort ist uns nun der bürgermeister
der stadt zugeschaltet kuba wieder
petrovic genannte petrovic
guter kalina
guten abend guten abend an alle sie
leiten die verteidigung der stadt jetzt
als bürgermeister in welcher lage
befinden sie sich im moment
bereits acht tage heute
gab es einen bombenangriff unsere
pfarrer werner zentrale wurde
die meisten häuser blieben ohne wärme
und wir haben ebenfalls angriffe erlebt
auf unsere stromverteilung
in den ersten tagen
mussten wir viele beschlüsse mit den
raketen der uran und grad ertragen und
danach kam nur noch die bomben ob vom
himmel
sie sind von haus aus eigentlich chirurg
sie haben die orthopädische abteilung
des krankenhauses ihrer stadt geleitet
wie es stets in mänteln die medizinische
versorgung bekommen sie überhaupt noch
hilfsmittel und anderes in die stadt
hinein oder sind bei ihnen schon die
versorgungslinien abgeschnitten durch
gesprengten brücken oder ähnliches
alles stabil
natürlich
vorrat an arzneimitteln lang medikamente
ein etwas
eingeschränkt
allerdings kann hier nicht genug nicht
genug vorgenannte der blutgerinnung
mitte und wir haben keine möglichkeit
dass heutzutage zu besorgen pedro wird
sie waren sie haben studiert in der
stadt fachkräfte 90 km entfernt ist von
ihm die stadt soll fast schon
eingenommen worden sei man hört ja immer
wieder unterschiedliche so das schaffen
ist die bürger von rajiv sich zu
verteidigen was hören sie von dort
zu fuß vor ihrer freundin
und anderem
fast food essen telefoniert einer von
ihnen ein
professor ist bereits die stadt
verlassen dass der andere
freund erzählt dass die ganze stadt mit
ist und es gibt keine möglichkeit sich
dort aufzuhalten
gibt es die möglichkeit aus ihrer stadt
noch zu fliehen oder ist das bei diesen
bombardierungen moment eigentlich gar
nicht mehr möglich
wir bereiten uns
für die morgige evakuierung vor und zwar
versuchen wir die menschen nach poltawa
auszufahren und
an der stelle brach bei der aufzeichnung
für einer halben stunde die er sehr
wackelige leitung endgültig zusammen so
dass ich mich von bürgermeister petrovic
auch nicht verabschieden konnte wir sind
mit ihm aber weiter in kontakt
was russland ihnen antut werden diese
ukraine nicht vergessen putins gerede
heute wieder russen und ukrainer seien
ein volk ist in ihren ohren nur noch
hohn putin isoliert sein land womöglich
auf lange zeit dass bei der abstimmung
in der uno vollversammlung sogar die
meisten zentralasiatischen
nachbarstaaten sich gestern enthielten
statt mit russland zu stimmen sprach
bände jetzt haben auch noch georgien und
moldau eiligst eine eu mitgliedschaft
beantragt kein wunder jeder sieht ja was
ein blühen kann wenn man ungeschützt in
russlands nachbarschaft liegt doch wie
kann den ukrainern jetzt noch geholfen
werden direkte köpfe werden sich die
nato staaten mit russland nicht liefern
aber immer mehr waffen liefern sie auch
deutschland heike slansky
soll da wie für den frieden die hatte
auch die ddr hier ein uralter propaganda
film zu sehen die flugabwehrrakete typs
trainer hergestellt in der alten
sowjetunion
mit ihr sollen jetzt mehr als drei
jahrzehnte später russlands truppen in
der ukraine gestoppt werden
wir liefern jetzt in summe
panzerbrechende waffen also boden boden
wirkung und boden luft wirkung das heißt
hier zusätzlich auch noch mal aus nva
beständen mit dem man zb drohen
abschießen kann mit dem man zb
kampfhubschrauber abschießen kann
altbestände aus der ddr die laut
beschaffungsamt der bundeswehr noch im
januar zur verschrottung freigegeben
wurden teilweise sind die kisten von
schimmel befallen allerdings so heißt es
ist die sicherheit der raketen davon
nicht betroffen
in der vor aufzeichnung der zdf sendung
maybrit illner am abend fordert scholz
eine waffenruhe in der ukraine und
erklärt warum deutschland mit alten
gewissheiten gebrochen hat bislang galt
keine waffenlieferungen in krisengebiete
nach dem angriff auf die ukraine wäre es
falsch dass jetzt noch fortzusetzen an
dieser stelle weil wir ja jetzt nicht
mehr verhindern können dass es diesen
krieg gibt es gibt ihn und da darf man
diejenigen die unschuldig angegriffen
worden sind nicht alleine lassen
deutschlands kehrtwende
panzerabwehrwaffen und
boden-luft-raketen des typs tiger sind
bereits am samstag auf den weg gebracht
worden zu spät meinen experten flugzeuge
können die nicht mehr nach tief bringen
die würden sofort abgeschossen werden
also müssen sie auf dem landweg gekommen
das wird dauern ob die jetzt rechtzeitig
da sind ist eine ganz große frage der
ukrainische botschafter in berlin kämpft
unermüdlich an der beschaffungs front
dankbar für den sinneswandel der
bundesregierung wird seine wunschliste
immer länger jetzt wo wir schon mitten
in diesem krieg sind der auf unserem
gebiete tobt in dieser dimension dann
glauben wir schon dass auch unsere bitte
gerechtfertig ist dass uns auch panzer
gepanzerte wagen aber auch vielleicht
flugzeuge drohnen und anderes
kriegsgerät geliefert wird die linke
warnt davor dass sie waffen den russen
in die hände fallen könnten während die
union an der seite der ampel steht wir
haben uns darauf verständigt
verteidigungswaffen zur verfügung zu
stellen egal welches waffensystem ist
jetzt im einzelnen ist es ist immer
darauf ausgerichtet einen aggressor zu
bekämpfen ob diese alten bestände der
ddr geliefert werden darüber entscheidet
demnächst der geheim tagende
bundessicherheitsrat
der scholz regierung
wolle mit einem sicherheitsexperten
sprechen mit carlo masala professor für
internationale politik an der
universität der bundeswehr in münchen
und auch hier im heutigen land
inzwischen ein vertrautes gesicht
genannt der professor maser lang
russland zu den merkwürdigen
nebenwirkungen eines solchen krieges
gehört ja dass man sich auch als
militärischer laie wie es die meisten
unserer zuschauer sind plötzlich mit
waffensystemen und solchen fragen
beschäftigt das was jetzt unter anderem
deutschland liefert zum beispiel solche
flugabwehrraketen bringt das jetzt
eigentlich den ukrainern also der armee
dort überhaupt noch was oder ist das
eher symbolisch
nein also das was jetzt geliefert wird
seit letzter woche ist nicht symbolisch
sondern hat durchaus einen realen
militärischen wert also die sieger zum
beispiel kann durchaus dazu beitragen
die russische luftüberlegenheit jetzt
nicht zu brechen aber es schwieriger zu
machen russische flugzeuge sozusagen
ihre angriffe zu fliegen und alles was
boden boden raketen sind hilft den
ukrainern den vormarsch russischer
verwende zumindest zu verzögern oder gar
in teilen zu stoppen also von daher es
gibt einen militärischen mehr wert aber
wir dürfen uns keine illusionen hingeben
der wird nicht dazu führen dass da jetzt
sozusagen das ganze spielt sich umdreht
und ihm keine armee plötzlich in die
offensive gehen kann und den russen
wirklich massive verluste zufügen hat da
kriegen sie jetzt eher pessimistisch
also es wird ja auch zum beispiel
darüber diskutiert warum die russen in
am boden zu mindestens zum teil mit sehr
alten panzern und sehr sehr jungen
soldaten unterwegs sind die zum teil
plündern weil sie nicht mehr genug zu
essen haben also scheint da der
nachschub nicht zu funktionieren kann es
nicht auch sein dass die russische armee
vielleicht gar nicht so gut ausgerüstet
ist wie sie mal behauptet hat dass da
viel durch korruption abgeflossen ist
ich weiß nicht ob es durch korruption
abgeschlossen ist aber was wir
feststellen ist sozusagen das ganze
hightech gerät was uns die russen seit
2008 immer medial präsentiert haben in
der ukraine nicht vorzufinden ist und
wir müssen jetzt ganz einfach
eingestehen dass das bild das wir über
die russische armee hat und seit 2008
seit dem beginn der großen militärreform
sehen dadurch beeinflussen was die
russen uns glauben lassen wollten jetzt
sehen wir in der ukraine dass die russen
in ihrer operationsführung viele sachen
die eigentlich basics sind einfach nicht
beachten also eine grottenschlechte
logistik die dazu führt dass sozusagen
kein diesel da ist panzer liegen bleiben
keine feldküchen da sind soldaten nach
34 tagen einfach nichts mehr zu essen
haben und das sind kapitale fehler
anfängerfehler in dem sinne wie wir den
russen eigentlich so nicht zugetraut
haben und jetzt erstellen so zu sagen
sie sind in ihrer operationsführung
nicht viel weiter und moderner geworden
es bleibt die frage was jetzt eigentlich
das militärische ziel ist also in
tschetschenien krieg putin damals zum
beispiel die einzige große stadt in dem
land grosny in schutt und asche gelegt
da stand ja kein stein mehr auf dem
anderen aber die ukraine ist ja nicht
für themen da sind ganz viele städte
will er die alle jetzt dann verwüsten
weil er anders nicht gewinnen kann was
glauben sie
ich glaube nicht dass wir die alle
verlusten will aber sozusagen wir sehen
an vielen städten sozusagen das jetzt
rein geschossen wird es hat noch nicht
die qualität wie sozusagen die
operationsführung in grosny oder was die
russen zusammen mit den mit den syrern
in aleppo gemacht haben aber der krieg
wird härter der krieg wird brutaler und
es geht um die strategisch wichtigen
städte die jetzt alle unter beschuss
sind und hier muss man das einfach sagen
ist die russische operationsführung
jetzt auch mehr in richtung rote lied
und gewalt gegenüber zivilisten
übergegangen und das werden wir
sicherlich in den nächsten tagen noch
wie viel stärker erleben
dann sind wir jetzt ja quasi in
irgendeiner form ihr auch militärisch
beteiligt wenn wir waffen liefern meinen
sie dass die russen das als provokation
empfinden es gab der dieser etwas
eigenartige verletzung des luftraums
über schweden das sah aus wie achtung
passt bloß auf was ihr tut oder wie
peter praet ihren sie dass
die verletzungen des luftraums über
schweden glaube steht im zusammenhang
mit der debatte in schweden und auch in
finnland über
einen nato beitritt und darauf hat ja
sozusagen den finnen und schweden briefe
geschrieben in denen er sozusagen harte
sicherheitsgarantien verlangt mit blick
auf russland also ich glaube das hat
nichts mit diesen waffenlieferungen
jetzt erst mal von unserer seite zu tun
und man muss einfach sagen waffen dürfen
geliefert werden dass die russen und
jetzt möglicherweise auf der verbalen
ebene als eine indirekte kriegspartei
ansehen das haben wir nicht in der hand
weil die russen sozusagen sich ihre
narrativ selber bilden wie sie wollen
aber wenn man es rein völkerrechtlich
betrachtet dann sind wir nicht in
direkte konfliktpartei und von daher ist
die waffenlieferung eigentlich keine
gefahr für die bundesrepublik
deutschland sein professor kann einmal
sah ich danke für ihre expertise und das
gespräch
danke ihnen
und wenn sie den menschen in der ukraine
und jeden auf der flucht helfen wollen
können sie spenden zum beispiel beim
aktionsbündnis katastrophenhilfe
stichwort zdf nothilfe ukraine die bahn
de 65 104 106 100 104 106 100 und alle
infos auch unter spenden punkt zdf.de
als oder im zdf text auf seite 8 190
allein in der ersten kriegswoche sind
schon mehr als eine million menschen aus
der ukraine geflüchtet und es werden
noch sehr viel mehr werden der
europäischen innenminister haben sich
heute darauf geeinigt dass sie alle
umgehend und unbürokratisch einem
zunächst einjähriges aufenthaltsrecht
bekommen
flucht bei eiseskälte die angst
beschossen zu werden während man mit den
kindern in einem langen track feststeckt
oder an bahnhöfen versuchten überfüllte
züge zu kommen viele deutsche haben das
im zweiten weltkrieg selbst erlebt in so
vielen familien hierzulande gibt es
diese geschichten die eltern und
großeltern erlebt haben und erzählen und
jetzt sehen wir all das vor unserer
haustür history repeating stephan
merseburger berichtet wie geflüchtete in
berlin ankommen
und wieder ist ein zug mit flüchtlingen
aus der ukraine in berlin angekommen
gestern waren es 4000 die registriert
wurden heute wahrscheinlich noch mehr
sie sind in sicherheit endlich aber müde
oder erschöpft
ich war sieben tage unterwegs meine
reise gegenüber ungarn und österreich
ich habe gestern keine unterkunft in
berlin gefunden deshalb bin ich heute
wieder hier um zu helfen
ich habe eine gewaltige explosion in der
nähe meines hauses gehört wir hatten
furchtbare angst wir haben drei tage im
keller verbracht die kinder haben
angefangen zu husten und hatten erhöhte
temperatur
[Musik]
helfer bieten essen und trinken an
masken und auch kleidung einige berliner
kommen um flüchtlinge bei sich zu hause
aufzunehmen
und alles was halt dann also ich glaube
zwei personen mit kleinem kind wäre
ideal
berlin charlottenburg der lagerraum
eines hotels sie sortieren spenden
mitglieder der rabatt gemeinde bereiten
die ankunft von waisenkindern aus der
ukraine vor also kinder aus einem
kriegsgebiet rauszuholen ist schon
motivation genug
sie nach berlin zu holen wir als als
jüdische gemeinschaft in berlin als
jüdische kinder sie aufnehmen zu können
und für sie da zu sein ist natürlich
noch mal eine doppelte motivation
sie sind mit bussen in odessa
aufgebrochen gestern haben sie die
moldawische grenze passiert 120 jüdische
waisen aus einem heim kleinkinder kinder
und jugendliche werden von betreuern
begleitet
[Musik]
kuscheltiere erwarten die kinder in den
hotelbetten die idee ist wirklich so
viel alltag wie möglich
zu gestalten das heißt kleinere kinder
in den kindergarten und die vorbereitung
die man im kindergarten macht und die
etwas ältere natürlich auch schulische
sachen anzubieten wer nicht weiß wohin
wird zur zentralen anlaufstelle in
reinickendorf gebracht berlin kann nicht
alle flüchtlinge beherbergen ist aber
zentraler drehpunkt brandenburg sachsen
und niedersachsen haben heute ukraine
aufgenommen wie viele noch kommen werden
ist ungewiss gewiss dagegen ist die
herausforderung wird außerordentlich
[Musik]
zu all den allzu bekannten grausamen
folgen eines jeden krieges kommt bei
diesem noch eine zusätzliche dimension
hinzu die kernkraftwerke im land das
unglück von tschernobyl hatte in der
sowjetunion ja nicht zu einer abkehr von
der atomkraft geführt mehr als die
hälfte ihres stroms mit ct ukraine aus
ihren akw und die liegen jetzt in einem
kriegsland da braucht man über den
einsatz russischer nuklearwaffen noch
gar nicht nachzudenken und sich längst
schon zu fragen welche risiken damit
womöglich lauern damit haben sich kein
felix jochens und kamera vier jahren
befasst
das kernkraftwerk sapori cia in der süd
ost ukraine
seltene aufnahmen aus dem jahr 2016
schon damals ist die technik veraltet
und wartungs bedürftig störfälle gibt es
immer wieder schwelbrände im
ventilationssystem lecks in der
kühlanlage das akw liegt jetzt im
kriegsgebiet und das löst bei der
internationalen atomenergiebehörde große
sorgen aus sie fordert russland auf
gefechte in der nähe von kernkraftwerken
zu unterlassen denn
es gab schon fälle in denen nuklearer
einrichtungen oder die unmittelbare
umgebung versehentlich oder auch nicht
versehentlich getroffen wurden durch
artillerie und in einem fall sogar durch
eine rakete es besteht also durchaus die
möglichkeit dass etwas passiert dass die
sicherheitsstrukturen beeinträchtigt das
austreten von radioaktivität verhindern
[Musik]
in der ukraine gibt es vier aktive
kernkraftwerke mit insgesamt 15
reaktoren sapori cia hat alleine sechs
es ist die mit abstand größte anlage
russische truppen rücken auf das akw vor
ukrainische bürger versuchen die
zufahrtsstraßen zu blockieren momentan
läuft der betrieb weiter durch die
regulären fachkräfte aber was könnte
passieren wenn die kämpfe noch näher
kommen und russland das akw einnimmt die
situation dort ist wirklich sehr
kritisch einmalig und hat es in der form
noch nie gegeben
am dom kraftwerke brauchen
funktionierende infrastruktur und auch
die mannschaft ist genau auf diesen
reaktor geschult das heißt probleme in
der infrastruktur strom ausfallen sind
sehr kritische situationen und eine
betriebsmannschaft kann man auch nicht
einfach so austauschen der russische
vertreter bei der internationalen
atomenergiebehörde gibt an sein land
hätte keine absicht in den betrieb der
kernkraftwerke einzugreifen es wird sich
zeigen ob das stimmt denn auch die
strategische bedeutung der ukrainischen
atomkraft ist enorm
wichtig ist die tatsache dass diese
anlagen mehr als die hälfte mehr als die
hälfte des stroms des landes liefern das
allein sagt schon viel aus
das akw sapori cia in der süd ost
ukraine abend idylle am riesen
atommeiler seltene aufnahmen aus dem
jahr 2016 heute herrscht hier krieg
und jetzt macht hans wolff weiter mit
weiteren nachrichten zum ukraine krieg
aber auch noch zu anderen themen
bundespräsident steinmeier war heute in
litauen zu gesprächen mit präsidentin
aus seyda und einem besuch des von der
bundeswehr geführten nato gefechts
verbandes in ruckler er dankte den
soldatinnen und soldaten für ihren
einsatz
steinmeier sagte weiter die botschaft
aus deutschland zeigt klar die
bündnissolidarität gelte ohne wenn und
aber
präsidenten aus jeder dankte für die
jüngste aufstockung des deutschen
kontingents in seinem land um rund 350
soldatinnen und soldaten
nach der spd spitze hat auch
bundeskanzler scholz den früheren
regierungschef und parteivorsitzender im
jahr hat schröder dazu aufgefordert
seine posten bei russischen
staatsunternehmen niederzulegen scholz
sagte der zdf sendung maybrit illner
mein rat an gerhard schröder ist doch
sich aus diesen ämtern zurückzuziehen er
betonte auch dass diese frage keine
privatsache sei die spd vorsitzenden
klingbeil und esken haben schröder in
einem brief ebenfalls dazu aufgefordert
seinen posten nieder zu legen
zehntausende haben sich nach einem
aufruf der frau des computer
organisation deutschlandweit an
friedensdemonstrationen für die ukraine
beteiligt ukrainische aktivisten hatten
ihre mitstreiter weltweit um deren
unterstützung gebeten die demonstranten
forderten unter anderem schärfere
strafmaßnahmen gegen russland und den
ausstieg aus fossilen energien
der deutsche industrie und
handelskammertag gegen bislang von einem
exportwachstum von sechs prozent für
dieses jahr aus dihk
außenwirtschaftschef dreier sagt nun das
sei nicht mehr zu schaffen und verweist
auch auf die probleme in den
lieferketten frank bethmann wie groß
sind diese probleme ja die werden von
tag zu tag größer etliche unternehmen
haben sich ja bereits aus russland
zurückgezogen heute kündigte diesen auch
volkswagen an und stellt die produktion
von fahrzeugen in russland ein zudem
werden die exporte von dort mit
sofortiger wirkung gestoppt doch das ist
nicht alles der krieg in der ukraine
bremst wegen fehlender teile bereits
jetzt die fahrzeugproduktion in
deutschland aus volkswagen kündigte an
dass es erneut zu arbeitsausfällen
kommen werde in den werken zwicker
wolfsburg und hannover zulieferteile
etwa aus der west ukraine würden fehlen
das beklagt auch bmw von dort kommen
keine kabelbäume mehr daher muss die
produktion im größten europäischen werk
in dingolfing nächste woche vermutlich
komplett gestoppt werden der ukraine
kriegt den dax heute unter
13.700 punkte ein minus von mehr als 300
zählern die meisten ahnen das war noch
längst nicht alles die weltwirtschaft
droht und eine rezession zu stürzen
längst ist klar sämtliche konjunktur und
inflationsprognosen müssen neu berechnet
werden frank bethmann vielen dank
frankreichs staatspräsident im manuellen
makro stellt sich für eine zweite
amtszeit zur wahl das wurde am abend
bekannt gegeben makro ist seit 2017 im
amt und die präsidentschaftswahl ist für
april vorgesehen die staatsanwaltschaft
frankfurt am main ermittelt gegen einen
ehemaligen verantwortlichen des
deutschen fußball-bundes und ließ in
diesem zusammenhang heute die
dfb-zentrale geschäftsräume von fünf
unternehmen sowie eine privatwohnung
durchsuchen es geht um den verdacht der
untreue
der ex funktionär soll im namen des dfb
scheinverträge mit einer
kommunikationsagentur geschlossen haben
in australien entschuldigung die
menschen im osten australiens kämpfen
weiter gegen das schwerste hochwasser
seit jahrzehnten die behörden meldeten
bisher 14 tote mehrere menschen werden
vermisst ganze landstriche stehen unter
wasser in sydney waren hunderttausende
aufgefordert ihre häuser zu verlassen
der niederschlag fiel dort jedoch
geringer aus als erwartet auslöser für
das extremwetter ist allen sich nur
langsam bewegende steve druck gibt
ja so viele erstmal von unserem heute
journal auf zdf heute halten wir sie
online natürlich immer weiter auf dem
laufenden und um 0.35 gibt es dann das
heute schnell update mit christopher
wehrmann und jetzt gleich geht es weiter
mit maybrit illner und ihrem
gesprächsgast bundeskanzler olaf scholz
auch wiedersehen wieder sinn
[Musik]
guten abend die tiefdruck gelände
westlich von uns hält abstand und das
liegt an dem hoch lino das bringt uns
auch morgen mit einer nordöstlichen
strömung sehr kühle temperaturen aber
auch wolken und aus diesen wolken kann
es sogar in sachsen ein bisschen
schneiden das geht schon heute nacht los
das sind so einzelne schnee sterne
einzelne schneeflocken das wird in
keinem fall viel werden es sind eben
auch schon wolken unterwegs die der von
nordosten heranziehen häufig aber ist
der himmel klar hier zwischen den
ostfriesischen inseln und der donau am
alpenrand kann es einige wolkenfelder
geben die temperaturen sinken in dieser
nacht auf null grad an den küsten von
ost und nordsee im binnenland geht's auf
-2 bis -8 grad runter und morgen liegen
die höchsttemperaturen zwischen der
ostseeküste und dem östlichen alpenrand
bei 1 bis 6 grad im westen wird es bei 7
bis 11 grad milder und vor allen dingen
im westen strahlt morgen die sonne im
osten dagegen sind die wolken dichter
und es kann auch ein bisschen schneien
immer noch im erzgebirge hier in der
lausitz da kommt wohl nicht mal eine
sonnenstunde zustande im westen dagegen
erwarten wir morgen das astronomische
mögliche maximum von gut elf
sonnenstunden
ähnlich geht es auch in den nächsten
tagen weiter also im osten ist es
häufiger bewölkt da gibt es auch nebel
und hochnebel und es ist merklich kälter
im westen dagegen scheint häufig die
sonne und es wird etwas milder
guten abend